[Music]
uh-oh you just fell into a pool with
this thing what is this
how would falling in here affect your
health and could you actually survive
this this is what if and here's what
would happen if you fell into a pool
full of spent nuclear fuel rods this is
a spent nuclear fuel pool and you've
just accidentally fallen into it but
what exactly is this thing this large
pool of water is meant to cool spent
fuel rods after they come out of a
nuclear reactor while powering a nuclear
reactor these fuel rods become very very
hot we're talking 2800 degrees after
it's spent three to six years inside of
a nuclear reactor a fuel rod is no
longer efficient problem is it still
emits plenty of harmful radiation and it
will for the next 10,000 years even
though it's trash there's not a garbage
dump in the world that will accept it so
why is water a good place to put these
things not only does the water spend
several decades cooling the fuel rods
but it also affects their radiation the
water essentially acts as a biological
shield with hydrogen absorbing and
deflecting the radiation bouncing
against it this makes it completely safe
for you to stand near the pool with no
ill effects but what happens if you fall
in the water well as soon as you orient
yourself you'll quickly notice the
temperature of the pool this big tub of
water won't be the refreshing dip you're
looking for on a hot summer day instead
it'll be around 30 degrees so a bit
colder than your average hot tub but
still very warm let's hope you didn't
accidentally turn off the water flow as
you're falling into the pool if you did
then you'd be in some serious trouble
spent nuclear fuel pools are constantly
cycling out water in order to keep it at
a cool enough temperature
these fuel rods are incredibly hot and
if the water isn't cycled out then it
would heat up significantly and slowly
evaporate over time resulting in you
burning to a crisp
but that didn't happen so now that
you're starting to swim in this hot pool
of water
when does the horrible radiation
poisoning kick in or when do you turn
green and start to gain superpowers
these are the sort of things that are
supposed to happen when you fall into
something that has nuclear fuel in it
right not exactly
although that sounds like fun it
wouldn't happen to you if you fell into
a spent nuclear fuel pool that's because
of the water not only does it protect
the people outside of the pool it'll
also protect you if you happen to fall
inside one as long as you don't swim
several meters underwater to touch the
fuel rods you'd be completely fine yeah
in theory you could swim in this pool
until you look like a raisin without
feeling any negative effects although
they're protecting something incredibly
dangerous spent nuclear fuel pools are
quite serene and kind of boring in fact
this might be a lot cleaner and safer
than your average public pool you won't
find any germs or children peeing in the
water here and swimming in this pool
would expose you to less radiation than
you experience in your everyday life we
encounter radiation in medical
procedures such as x-rays and CT scans
from certain fuels like gas or coal even
our televisions and other screens give
off tiny traces of radiation swimming in
here isn't any more dangerous than
watching a what if video if splashing
around in a spent nuclear fuel pool is a
little too boring for you how about
swimming on one of Saturn's moons well
that sounds like a story for another
what if
[Music]